en vos ni sientes que la maniobra rusa
no funcionó como se esperaba
varios vehículos blindados son
remolcados
otro de ellos sigue a mi lado de esta
carretera una de las principales vías de
acceso por las que los soldados rusos
decidieron atacar
vitaly participó en la batalla los
atacamos cerca del puente bum
bum y muy pronto sus pilas
desaparecieron ucrania era nuestra es
nuestra y será nuestra no tienen nada
que hacer aquí durante tres días los
soldados rusos tomaron posiciones en las
casas del barrio
incluso dejaron sus cosas
voy a mostrarles
estas son sus raciones
dice ejército rusa
ramón estaba en el sótano de su vecino
cuando volvió a casa descubrió que los
rusos no se habían ido con las manos
vacías
estuvieron en mi casa me vieron con
miedo escucharon todas las cosas de los
niños las mías seguramente estaban
buscando oro o dinero no sé en todo caso
me robaron mis analgésicos mi perfume
coyanco de alcohol también se llevaron
mis herramientas mis llaves inglesas la
llave inglesa para el auto y todas las
herramientas eléctricas había cosas de
estos soldados rusos tiré todo sombrero
camisetas guantes seca laurent de ropa
porque la mía desapareció mi chaqueta
más abrigadas deben seguir usándolas
porque ya no están aquí esta gente solo
merece ser asesinada como asesinan a
nuestros hijos
su vecino de 80 años todavía está
enfadado manejaron para meterse al patio
ya la puerta está rota y allá también no
hablé con ellos porque no tengo nada que
decirle
sergei se atrincheró en la entrada de la
ciudad
me siento mejor desde que pusimos los
sacos de arena la construí desde los
primeros días es importante
por la noche sigue durmiendo en el
sótano de su casa el peligro sigue ahí
al parecer sigue estando por acá porque
hace unos días varios soldados rusos que
merodeaba cerca
fueron capturados por nuestra gente en
la zona
es probable que sigan sí así que nunca
salimos de noche porque es peligroso
sabemos que pueden entrar a las casas
para buscar comida y ropa
sergei está pensando en enviar a su
mujer e hijos a salvo al extranjero
aquí todos saben que el ejército ruso
intentará volver así que pues ni 100 que
está preparada
el anual de 32 años está en primera
línea
antes de su elección era un joven
empresario ahora se forma en tácticas
militares
o la más los puentes pero sabíamos que
el enemigo podía cruzar el río así que
con algunos empresarios estábamos este
lado del río e hicimos una presa solo 20
horas antes de que el enemigo se
acercará a la ciudad para que los
tanques y los blindados no pudieran
pasar habría preferido no hacerlo pero
su ciudad tiene un valor estratégico si
mykolaiv en el sur vuelan los puentes no
hay otra manera de llegar a odessa o a
kiev la capital sólo a través de nuestra
ciudad así que nos estamos preparando
para volver a ver al enemigo la segunda
central nuclear más potente del país
está a 30 km pero el alcalde sabe que
tiene una ventaja decisiva
hoy no tenemos enemigos en la ciudad ya
no tenemos digamos viejas rencillas o
desacuerdos hoy nos damos la mano para
defendernos estas barricadas que ven
fueron construidas en parte por mis
asistentes por los productores de
elección por los panaderos todos
participan nuestro mismo
muchos civiles se convirtieron en
combatientes como este propietario de un
restaurante orgulloso de su café casero
y de su compromiso
realmente creo que vamos por buen camino
mayor motivación para definir lo que
es
ganar dinero así que mentalmente más
niveles que nosotros que defendían como
reputados
dice que siempre es más fácil luchar
cuando se sabe por qué